they look like a Nazi and a Nazis son
and I hate them I hate the photograph I
hate the people in it I want to kill
them both
hi my name is sue Kuhn and I'm very
excited because today I'm gonna talk to
myself and how are you very good like
yeah I like the I like the getup
I like yours too it's almost as good
very nice shoes for the way very nice
yeah thank you thank you yeah do the bit
of a Polish the first question is what's
your favorite impression to do equality
Martin Sheen because normally I squash
something against the roof of my mouth
to do Martin Sheen to make my mouth
cavity smaller because he's speaking as
if his wife small like that he goes yeah
I'm the President of the United States
and when he's sure she gets real horse
he's guy's voice get squeaky like that
that's quite good that's quite good but
be lost on anyone under 50 which acts as
Korea are you most jealous of oh hello
Cary Grant oh that's good he's dead that
won't cause you any problems given a
bump into him like well like to had
Peter Sellers career without the by that
being a dysfunctional horrible person
she was again dead what about modern
actors yeah I mean gosh Will Ferrel
quite let's have his career not going to
happen might might happen what's your
favorite Will Ferrell film
well I quite like Alf what did you have
to do to get into character for greed I
mean I could go around the houses but
and say that I've tried and and to find
influence from various different people
but the bottom line is I just watched
videos of Philip Green he comes across
as a really nice guy when was the moment
you realized that you were famous
I would think when a policeman let me
off about 30 years ago cause I was you
know I probably had just started any
money so I bought a little like a hot
hatch and he did the kind of who the
hell do you think you are Nigel Mansell
and you know it's you isn't it even yeah
but it's funny I although you know slow
down all right go on off you go that's
interesting she's saying she knew
doesn't new famous was when you did
something corrupt and corrupted a police
officer yeah great okay what's been the
strangest interaction you ever had with
a fan someone once asked me to sign an
autograph by pushing it under the
cubicle door and was in a lavatory and
another guy was at the urinal once and
immediately stopped peeing and turned to
his hand and put it out to shake hands
with me it's disgusting and I said well
you've just been touching your penis do
you want to wash your hands first what
did you do with your autograph I just
said I don't think this is an
appropriate you know yeah it would have
been funny if you'd said I wipe my ass
with it but you you weren't thinking
quick enough okay what is your biggest
pet peeve people who say H instead of
age when it's H and not H unless you're
Irish then you can say H but anyone else
in Britain or America who says hey CH a
said of H really gets on my nerves I
agree the only thing really bothers me
are those advocacy for patek philippe
watches that say you don't just own a
patek philippe you just look after it
for the next generation and it they look
like a Nazi and a Nazi son and I hate
them I hate the photograph I hate the
people in it I want to kill them both
and whenever I see it on the back of
magazine I want to tear it to pieces I
just absolutely hate those adverts I
hate the people who came up with hate
whoever wrote it yeah I agree with it it
looks like an advert for tax avoidance
that's what it was like to me not for a
watch if you weren't an actor what job
would you have a volunteer assassin
right well okay that's not a job so if
you could play a famous person in
history who would it be Oliver Cromwell
because I'm really fascinated by that
that period in British history oh
there's a civil war where we had a civil
war just a bit like brexit except we
were killing it literally killing each
other
hmm sounds interesting okay lovely did
you have a good time
I've had worse times that's very
gracious of you
you